[Music]
hello
[Music]
are we live
hello
can you all hear me
[Music]
hello
hopefully we're live i have no idea
actually
i stopped doing this for a week and then
i completely forget what i'm doing
completely
bye
why are you in my left ear
am i in in your left ear guys
that's not good
that'd be bad
hello
i'm actually on screen today wow
left ear huh uh oh that's bad uh
okay hold on
thank you for telling me i appreciate
that actually
why would this be happening i actually
don't know
hello
[Music]
i don't know why this would be a thing
[Music]
fixing fixing
gonna try to fix
was it good for a sec
unfixed okay
so maybe i did the right thing
now are we good
because i did this and i didn't think it
would work
audio is good when you said hello
it was good for one second
good now okay
man you guys are great you actually tell
me when stuff's wrong
twitch didn't do that
twitch they would just be like
it's fine
and just not tell me that the audio is
only coming out of the left side for
six hours
[Music]
hey jake a little fact if something is
masterpiece that is all time thing and
it can't be still a masterpiece
uh
i don't think so i think
something that we considered a
masterpiece back in the day
cannot be a masterpiece later on right
maybe maybe i'm wrong what do you think
i don't think so
[Music]
there's written master p heist on the
thumbnail something for some great
content
oh thank you s
i appreciate that man thank you is that
true
why can't i exit out of here
hello
uh-oh now you all know why is this like
this
hold on does it say masterpiece
it says masterpiece to me
on in the thumbnail
[Music]
yeah maybe you gotta
reload i don't know
um
yeah it looks fine
yeah it says masterpiece for me over
here okay
weird okay
what completionist are you gonna do next
i don't think we're gonna do a
completionist of this game
not the video title the thumbnail
no it says masterpiece in the thumbnail
as well
[Music]
just started your 100 completion of
elven ring don't spoil me hey
enjoy it it's all there for you to watch
we actually did it
i didn't think we would actually finish
that but we did
pretty cool
as long as it's not master piss
yeah
yeah true true
okay hold on
i want to record
i need to turn down
things here
graphical options
nice e girl on a polaroid that's one of
my friends
okay i forgot how to stream
forgot how to stream
there we go
a little loud for me
anyway uh how many of y'all or wait hold
on
okay here we go
i'm gonna record while streaming so that
we don't lose quality when i use the
stream for a video
pro content creator here uh how many of
y'all have played securo before
because i have like
100 hours
[Music]
in the game i think
me
i didn't i don't
nope
never
finished second play through a bleep
bloodborne scythe is the best weapon i
like the cleaver the one you get like
right at the beginning
is it worth the money how much is it
right now because i bought it when it
came out obviously
i don't know what it was on steam i
would say it's
probably less than 60 bucks right
it might still be 60 bucks i i have no
idea
no but should i
okay
so i
i think
that sakiro
could uh this is weird to say because
they're two completely different games
hero might be better than eldon ring
in its own
its own way because oh it's on sale sick
it's 50 off you should go get it then go
get this game right now if you this this
is one of
the best games i have ever played
absolutely this this was game of the
year in 2019
i believe point it came out march 2019
it came out on my birthday
in 2019. i remember that but this is
this game is unbelievably good but it's
not it's not like eldon ring this is a
very
linear i don't think even linear is the
right word because you can go wherever
the hell you want within the world of
shakiro
but
it's kind of like dark souls 3 dark
souls that can go wherever you want but
it's still a linear path of progression
whereas elden ring there's a bunch of
stuff everywhere
um
but i absolutely love this game
i love the combat like if you guys
haven't experienced the combat of this
game
it's the combat in this game is way
better than eldon ring uh
because elden ring
is like dark souls 3 with its combat
it's very you know like
you you roll
you dodge you get out of the way and
then you hit when you when you do the
roll right
skiro you don't dodge
you don't roll
you don't do any of that stuff
you deflect
you parry it's a completely different
combat system that i think is
excellent
my dad decided to mow can you see him
he's right there
nice
click new game please dude
i'm talking to chat man
we'll get into it i'm talking
damn
what's up metal how are you
oh yeah also i have the webcam on
i
if you didn't know what i look like
there you go i look like a normal person
very low frames i don't even think
there's a point in dodging in uh sakiro
except for some some stuff some stuff
but most of the time you're gonna
deflect you're gonna parry and that's
like
um if you guys have ever played guitar
hero
guitar hero
uh it's kind of like a rhythm
like you start to understand their
attacks and you have to time your
your deflect at the right time
or else
you know
you you get hit and you die
hitboxes in this game and talk is top
tier hey we're gonna i haven't played
this game in like two-ish years
i think i played it a little bit like
last year
um it's been a long time since i've
played the game
so
let's do it all right
we're gonna be comparing it to elden
ring because obviously that's all we've
been playing for the last four months
at least all i've been playing and i'm
definitely looking forward
to
something else
uh last question before we get started
press one in chat if you're a little bit
burnt out on elden ring it's a little
bit
one i'm pressing one i'm a little bit
i'm a little bit burnt
it's an amazing game but i've been
playing the absolute balls out of it
for
a while now for four months since it
came out
a little bit burnt
it's a great game but
gotta take a break from that stuff every
now and then you know what i'm saying
being at five times still going same i
think i've beaten elden ring like seven
or eight times
and then we did a whole completionist
run and i've just been i think i've been
burnt ever since we did that
yeah
so anyway
if you have never experienced securo
before here you go
this is sakura we're going to play
we're not going to do a completionist
run of this game at least i don't think
unless we you get really into it
but we're going to play as much as we we
want of it
and just kind of
not review it but
compare it to elden ring kind of see the
differences
so let's freaking do it dude
i absolutely love this game
love it love it love it
but maybe after eldon ring my opinions
may change i'm not sure that's kind of
why i want to replay it again
we're doing english
can you guys hear it
raged
is drew here
hi drew
english dub sucks this is not
an anime
this is not anime
turn it up all right
wait i can't yet
i can't turn it up yet
yeah we're gonna complain about the
english dub yup
hi drew
please be in my walls
english dub sucks
[Music]
jesus
i am
i'm not doing the span i'm doing english
[Music]
someone mentioned the body size that guy
must have been 450 pounds and like eight
feet tall
hi pascal
this game's annoyingly difficult i
disagree
i think once you get in the flow of the
combat of this game
it's pretty it's not easy
don't get me wrong what's the matter i
don't think it's
nothing left that crazy
drew thank you man
you look at that thanks for the
membership man i appreciate you bro
will you join me starving wolf drew in
chat right now guys is legitimately
eight feet tall i'm not kidding i met
him in real life he is an absolute
beast of a person trained relentlessly
and indeed
went on to become a master shinobi
i think
the last boss in this game is the best
boss fight in any souls game
i will
defend him
bring him back at any cost nice lorenzo
you understand al's really good too
there's a lot of great boss fights in
this game
regular eachine i'm talking like the the
main ending not the shura ending
the main ending where he has like four
phases best boss fight of all time some
twenty i think it is better than radon
lady butterflies cool too
what's up austin how are you man known
as wolf
had lost everything
my way or the highway
that's a good point pascal
there's not there's not a lot of freedom
in this game like you have to get good
at the uh deflecting combat or you're
not gonna do well in this game that that
is very true
metal aren't you like five two
i'd say you're like maybe five four
i don't remember
you have any tips on beating soldier of
godric
good luck
you won't
you can't beat them
open your eyes damn this looks good in
4k i haven't played this game in 4k yet
because we finally got in-game graphics
here that was all like kind of
pre-rendered cut scenes before
this looks clean
four foot eleven
nice we don't judge height here
like if you all had to guess how tall do
you think i am just me sitting here
right now
how do you like the difficulty of early
bosses in elden ring
i think the early game of elden ring is
excellent uh it gets a little like once
you hit mountaintops of the giants the
the difficulty kind of shoots up in a
kind of a stupid [ __ ] way
if you're short just don't be that's a
great way to put that drew through
two feet tall yeah you got it i'm only
two feet tall
we don't judge height only length
got 100 this game as well i don't know
we're just gonna play the game today and
kind of see how we feel
oh my god this game already looks really
good
furrows wolf your destiny awaits at the
moon view tower escape from the well and
find the tower bathed in moonlight
even without a blade you can reach it
stay silent stay vigilant
okay
mommy you can jump in this game holy
[ __ ]
i was expecting i forgot i don't know
why i forgot you can jump in this game i
was expecting dark souls 3 where you you
can't really jump
if you guys didn't know that eldon ring
was like one of the first souls games to
introduce jumping
joy is upset at something she is barking
her head off above me
yeah i know you can you know i'm gonna
play the game guys
i'm gonna play stealthy
we didn't shackle him restrain him
nothing
that doesn't worry anybody oh let me
turn up the thingy sorry
let me uh i'm gonna move it up a bit
to
here
let me know if this sounds better
not only is he unarmed he has completely
lost his will to live nothing but a
coward
unworthy of our concern
these are very con conveniently placed
conversations
can
eavesdrop the moonlight shines strongly
on the moonview tower tonight the divine
air is probably using the light for his
reading again probably but imprisoning a
mere child
i feel sorry for the boy agreed
that i'm sure lord ganesha has a very
convenient conversation yet again
yeah yoda is kind of a spammer
a bit of a spammer this one
goddamn i'm this game looks good in 4k
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
can you beat first kanichiro i haven't
played the game in like a year and a
half so no
but we're going to try
i'm just talking you know you can talk
without spamming bro that that is a
definite possibility i've seen it done
by everyone else in the chat
so you know
is the character a child
does wolf look like a child
no
yeah i'm on 60 fps
the gameplay i don't really enjoy it
listen
like pascal said earlier
it's you got to get good at the combat
or you're got not going to have a good
time
you're just not gonna have a good time
so and that's understandable as some
people don't get into it but i like
once you understand the combat which
took me
10 hours i think
uh
then it's
the best combat i've ever experienced in
a video game
nice sponsor thanks you guys should go
check out manscaped in the description
it's our first official sponsor and i i
really appreciate them for that you did
well to come here look i even put stuff
over here
it's been too long wolf
you can shave your nuts with this
my lord it has a light
well then
not shaving my face
pro content creator here raise your head
yeah let me just tell you that yoda
yoda how old are you man you give me y
very young vibes bro
i'm just saying
can i shave okay
yes you can shave off your depression in
accordance with the bond of lord and
retainer
you will pledge your life in my service
[Music]
no i don't have a mullet
i have long hair
as you command
it's it's not a mullet
everyone always says that
what the [ __ ] all right we got our sword
lit
loyal wolf i see you are wounded
i have something that may help it is a
special gourd of medicinal waters
600 wounds
all right buddy
there's our estes flash
or crimson tears
now then were you gravely injured
afterward after what do you know guys
this is a child i do not
no
we'll talk about the parallels between
learning the combat of this game and
learning a new fighting game as you say
there's a secret passage
yes i'd say it's a rhythm
once you find it
signal me with a reed whistle you know
oh no one sees the front of my hair i do
i always wear a hat
i always wear a hat
wolf
do you have something for me
give curls charm
this is for you my lord it's from that
time so you notice then
i see
he doesn't have a bowl cut you keep this
for me that's like cool anime hair but
this charm has protected you all this
time it's held your suffering at bay i
do not wish for you to suffer any more
than you are i did watch someone beat
this game with drums
which is kind of nuts
keep it in your care i see so by the way
if you give that charm away
it makes the game instantly harder
so if you want more difficulty
you give that to him
i don't want that
we are going to leave
do not push yourself too far you must
heal your wounds damn this game looks
really good
in 4k man
okay i actually have to equip items
again oh
how do i heal i don't remember
okay it's up on the d-pad
up
okay
yeah calamity ring basically
is the difficulty change reversible i
don't know actually
i don't think so
are you guys ready for this combat
yeah that guy got absolutely freaking
annihilated
yep
it is reversible okay good
all right deflection
this is what we need to learn
sometimes relentless attack is not
enough to break an enemy's posture so
this game's all about posture guys
nobody gives a [ __ ] about health
health is irrelevant in this game
posture is everything deflect enemy
attacks in another way to damage their
posture a master schnoby uses a
combination of deflect and attacks to
achieve
swift victory
so we're going to deflect this guy
insta kill
broke his posture immediately and now he
is dead
boom
rp walk right to these boys
not even close
didn't time that one right
boom
yeah like it's kind of dark right now so
we can't even see like how good the
world looks but once we get like past
genichiro up here
oh we got a boss
then we'll it'll look way better but
the two dots in the top left corner
i didn't know that guy was swinging bro
i didn't know where a boy was swinging
two dots in top left corner you gotta
uh break his posture twice
so i did it once
boom
yeah yeah
[Music]
there it is
i love how he wipes the blood off of his
thorn after he does that that's freaking
sick
uh but my posture is on the bottom you
can get it back by
standing like in this stance it's pretty
cool
oh i got a pellet
another way to heal are these pellets
how do i okay there we go
and it slowly heals you over time there
we go i gotta learn the controls again
i don't think ash is anything i don't
remember
yeah don't you have to beat the game to
um
to get the boss rush thing that they
added in
you know that secret passage at the
bottom of the moat
another very very conveniently placed
conversation
i would have never known of this secret
entrance if they did not speak of this
as i'm going past it amazing
oh you throw it to disorient enemies
you're right
troll under the bridge
gross
yes this is a stream
that'll probably turn into a video like
i'll edit up the stream and see
uh yeah
i'll edit it into a video after the
stream
this appears to be an escape route
called a divine error with the read
whistle
a mad pumpkin head it's a very small
pumpkin head
i think that's a great idea pascal
unfortunately i don't have uh
i don't have a ps4 anymore it doesn't
it doesn't work very well
now let us leave don't have a ps5 either
i can't get one
oh there's a harder issue
have fun editing three hours of footage
i will
it won't be that bad where shall we go
once we're away from the castle i
suppose the first thing we should do is
cross the ashina border or perhaps we
should good to hear waffle thanks man
whatever you desire whatever i desire
that's the wolf i know my lord
oh nothing
i was just reminiscing onward then
i think uh wolf is a simp
kind of what it seems like
what'd you do to your ps4 it just
overheated one day and to stop working
i think it's because i tried to play uh
red dead two on it
i didn't go well
see look at this dude
so pretty
by the way guys sakiro is 30 50 off
right now it's 30 bucks
so if you're thinking to get in the game
now would be the time last we stood
together was your uncle's funeral
lord gonichiro yes hopeless
i
you don't even gotta talk bro
i got this
guys is kiro a boy or a girl cause i
don't know
leave this to me
not that it really matters but
can we play cyberpunk
should we go back and look at cyberpunk
and see if they've like made the game
better or not it's a boy okay that's
what i thought
who's probably about to tear my [ __ ]
arm off
still a [ __ ] though
[Music]
good start
really good start
i don't have mikiri counter dog
i don't have mercury counter that's my
fault
we got backup out of that
we don't want no part of that
sweep
i'm lasting longer than i thought i
would
that's what she said
i'm honestly kind of owning him right
now
look at me go baby
[Music]
not bad though
yeah you just eat it off my arm that's
great
not bad though
i haven't played this game in a year and
a half
yep gotta restart
we go we gotta go again not all the
shinobi has to offer by the way even if
you beat him you get your arm eated off
anyway will be coming with me
tos gore it's a video game dog
ain't none of this real
imagine
yeah i'm on pc playing in 4k
is the stream in 4k
it should be
depending on your internet i have an
idea you become soldier of groddrick and
you make a stream where we pvp at the
look area main gate if we win you give
us an item an item
can you do that i have yet to touch
elden ring pvp haven't even touched it
bro but thank you for the 5 super chat
that's not a bad idea
we could do that
my guy flexes his 4k every 20 seconds
i'm just saying man i just got a 4k
monitor
i got a nice pc now i'm playing in 4k
except when this [ __ ] pops up on screen
that's my friend jen
yeah we're clearly doing a hit list run
here drew yeah
what is that my arm's gone
1440 okay it's not quite there but
that's that's great
so you're awake
looks like death is not your fault girls
don't play video games
that's not true
what the heck are these
okay shinobi prosthetics so that's my
prosthetic arm
kind of lit
kind of cool what is this
view remnant
wow
that was awesome so cool
what do you call yourself
nothing your eyes the eyes of a wolf who
has failed in his duties
or so
is this the origin story of melania
where i lost my arm
is it the same arm
left arm you do no it's your other arm
rip
ask how you got here ask about your new
left arm yeah how did i get here am i
here all i did was drag you here how did
you do that i didn't even know if i was
driving
dude it's millennials
person a pack of wild dogs what was the
name of that person who dragged melania
back to the halo tree
i forget
i forget since i found you
i see
however your master yet lives
this is her right arm that's what i was
saying his left arm's gone
finley thank you pastor okay thank you
i'm sure you appreciate the value it has
hey you got it jessica i'm glad i can
help
ass hospital day
you'll get through it we got this all
right
uh i would be more far more excited for
securo dlc than one for elden ring
well that's not gonna happen uh
we'll probably have sakiro too
maybe i don't know
this would you know yeah it's potential
what did you mean i just had a stroke
use of his bloodline i don't know much
about him except the dragon's heritage
there's a special kind of blood by that
name and that blood
we will
we will 100 play dark souls 2 on stream
just so you guys know might be that the
strange things happening to your body
have something to do with that
and we may hate it you're quite the
strange one yet
other peculiar visitors have come to
this temple there's one in the clearing
to the right of the gate leading off the
temple grounds two strangers shadows die
thrice circumstance yes sir you two
might get along
i'm not a huge fan of the headless
fights lorenzo but we'll do as much as
we please you know what i'm saying we'll
do we'll do as much as we want
oh this game looks good
i missed this game
this game is so freaking awesome
i randomly started crying okay
i do that sometimes i know i'm not on
this is like my first time using a
webcam i think on this channel
uh sometimes i randomly cry just
completely ignore that thank you
i've never seen you before okay i need
to fix that
won't tell me we'll we'll get through it
metal it'll be okay
or perhaps
sir please heed my humble request face
me in battle
oh
so this guy's a training guy
he's undead so he'll keep coming back to
life
but he'll train you damn pretty cool
still alive
damn still alive
bro
all right how are you still alive dog
that swordsmanship it was a thing to
behold few have managed to while the sun
is just beaming through here
what are you some call it undying others
infested i can't
this game really is like an
anime what the [ __ ] might come in handy
for whatever your mission is a warm body
that can't die might it's in the name
you're supposed to
die twice so if you die more than that
you failed wow well yeah
very well
right then
let's go wait what do we just do
swinging one sword is a cure for boredom
oh i see okay back whenever you like if
you have techniques to try out
i'm at your disposal
oh i never thought of that can i go back
with the mortal blade and kill this guy
i never thought of doing that i'm such
an [ __ ]
because he wants to die all right
all right let's check out the movement
check this out
what is it lt okay check it
like that's just that's sick
oh
wow okay i'm ruining the moment here we
go
damn
hey this probably doesn't look as good
for you as it does for me but [ __ ] this
looks good bro
like sheesh
it probably looks pretty good for you
too
he gives you an item that makes you die
whenever you want
not bad
guys you think i have a 4k monitor i
just got it so i'm gonna talk about it
okay
i just got it man i had one of my
monitors poop out on me too so i just
was like let's get a 4k monitor [ __ ] it
dude
security is good but bloodborne's the
best
i don't know
if i would like playing a game in 30 fps
right now
oh yeah
i like the money system
dude this movement is freaking
fire
we just avoid these guys
i can sneak up behind him
4k andy over here
can't even get 4ks in a round of
valorent i don't even want to talk about
valorent okay
actually valerie was fun
for
a little bit
should have gotten an 8k is 8k a thing
i will say the movement is very
different
from elden ring like obviously i'm super
used to elden ring right now
yeah sex is cool but have you ever had a
4k monitor i'm just saying guys
oh
oh there's a whole pack of them bro
oh
can i deflect the dog
where you going dog
all right lit
you didn't talk to emma
she's not at the beginning yet she will
be later
right
yeah
it requires too much setup
um
maybe
all right first boss fight
first boss fight
this guy's pretty tough
we'll see how it goes
uh
yeah perilous attacks you can't dodge
or you can't deflect i mean
nice
not a good start
[Music]
decent deflect
i'm just [ __ ] up this stuff no no no
no
very nice start
[Music]
my bad that was my fault
[Music]
nope
oh i think he got that off bro
he broke my posture tried to grab me
you smell
you're bad at the game
uh-uh
not bad
is ghost of jushima on uh on pc
yet
no way right
that was pretty good
i used to be pretty good at this game
and that just
is still a fact
i'm kidding i'm gonna die to something
out here
you can deflect thrust perilous actually
i used to train myself i remember
some of the inner variant of bosses have
super quick thrust perilous
okay i don't know if i want to try it
but we'll see
sadly not yet okay
okay
you know god of war came to uh
pc so
we'll see
you missed your first tool
i did
is it over here
see i don't remember where everything is
that's a fish full of ash doll
i wasn't ever really big on tools i like
the uh
i like just deflecting i don't know why
i'm kind of a weirdo
that's a pellet
jake is hot thanks oh wait [ __ ]
okay
don't ask me why i did that
ogre's pretty easy if you soak her
around circle around and attack randomly
ogre is hard
uh he i mean he can beat your ass
fast
i don't like these guys
oh wait i gotta go talk to grandma hold
on
hey yo what up
you should try the tools are really fun
i'll give them a shot
sorry i thought i was gonna get hit
there
[Music]
we also need to get makiri counter as
soon as possible
what up bro
what
i didn't hit deflect in time all right
we died we're dead we died to some rando
but but what's this what's this game
called
twice [ __ ]
you gotta kill me twice bro
can't kill me once
hey what up grandma
oh
is that you enosuke that's not my name
have you seen the young master
i am not your son try to say nothing i'm
gonna say nothing
what
nothing to say does your stomach hurt or
something
why are you in here not a weak stomach
well anyway take this bell it's a charm
i made with the young master in mine i
don't know how to kill double gorilla
boss without the tools
for his sake gorilla actually had like
stage two is way easier than stage one
young lords bell charm receive old woman
be offered to buddha so this is how we
go in the dream world right against
butterfly lady i believe
okay sick
let's go uh let's go beat up the ogre
i'm still getting used to the controls
again
very different from elden ring
i mean not super different
this feels different
like that right there like you were fast
as [ __ ] boy
i'm not gonna explain why there's a
giant rooster you just need to accept
that as fact okay
good
always say nothing it's a trap
of course of course
okay we rested you have to physically
rest it's not a
immediate thing
okay
hmm
eavesdrop i don't feel safe with that
big bastard just tied up next to us i'd
rather not be gravely injured just
before the war begins
okay yeah there's a grappling hook you
know it's it's pretty different
those red eyes fear fire
that's what the lord's proclamation said
proclamations
what a joke another conveniently placed
preparing for war conversation for us to
learn
up that the giants hate fire
[Music]
you attack me back bro
that guy a little bit stupid
i missed an npc
where is there an npc besides the old
lady we talked to the old lady
holy crap yoda stopped spamming bro
type out a full coherent sentence before
you hit enter my guy i would appreciate
that
this man
was from hirata i must pay my respects
oh the merchant
apologies there's no end to those who
seek the dragon's heritage
pathfinder because of those that pursued
me
the merchant's up on a hill somewhere
near here right
don't remember
let's go up here
uh a few people in chat said that this
game is 50 off right now i don't know if
that's true or not
don't take my word for it uh if it's not
true blame chat
okay
oh he's over there
is that where he is yeah with all the
crows
all right let's go check it out
[ __ ] it dude
uh-oh
it is a hundred percent true
oh you guys have lied to me before you
you very much have
it's on steam it's 50.
okay you guys said it was 30.
hey what up guy care to purchase an
offering
can you
indeed can this guy face me to be
offered to the dead so they might rest
in peace from the looks of you this guy
sounds sucks do you know a thing or two
about death go ahead
buy an offering
okay
oh you go sugar
roberts firecracker i don't have enough
for firecrackers yet
where you find the departed you'll find
the memorial mob just like the crows
wherever your travels take you make sure
you bring some offerings with you this
guy's so sus why does he also have his
ass facing towards me like what the f
what the heck dude
okay uh
you know what i just tried to do i tried
to pull up the map so i could fast
travel to
like elven ring bro
all right there's fall damage by the way
ball damage already better than elden
ring
i just forgot the lt
[Applause]
ignore the rooster
it is what it is
you ever play new game plus uh i don't
remember it's been a while since i
played this game at all
you're the one who walked around to his
ass i thought that was the opening
you could turn around
oh god
already trying to grab
look at these moves
i dodged
i swear i dodged
get back up
go again
i'm i'm clearly behind you dog
[Music]
clean hitboxes clean
oh i didn't think he'd do that bro cause
i'm so scared of your grab
is moog still a thing are we still
saying get mowed
secure would be better if we could
choose different classes and builds
that's not what this game is though this
is an elden ring it's a completely
different game
like this game is not meant to give you
a bunch of different options when it
comes to the combat
unlimited
guys
metal we should probably already make
the pin comment
to stop backseating and telling me what
to do
thank you
clean dodge
i can already tell that we're gonna need
that for today
already gonna need it
all right that one's a bit different
that one's a bit different
that that's understandable
no we're not stuck on the monk pole
we don't talk about that
[Music]
yo
yo
grab
right after rap nice
this guy wants to be in the wwe
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
yes
you guys can absolutely say jake get
better at the game and
i won't get mad about that but if you're
like jake go here jake do this jake do
that
you're kind of a forehead and you should
stop doing that thank you
we're just gonna play
we're just playing the game
yeah why no bloodhound step
oh yeah
is there a gourd seed up here yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay okay okay
we got a boss down here
bro
how much harder is akira compared to
dark souls uh totally different game so
i don't know like this game's combat is
completely different from eldon ring
sakiro all all that
watch minions the rise of gru
i don't want to do that
when do we get the moonville
let's not ruin this game
dog i didn't even see you
in your fat bald head
did i just get shot
let's go get our other gourd seed
where are the bleed procs
are we gonna be annoying today
i love it keep it up keep it up guys
keep it up
hello emma
how are you you truly
returned from the dead the power of the
dragon's blood i never thought joy's
excellent i own eyes
he'll probably come down here and lay on
the bed soon i am a doctor serving a
certain master what master
forgive eachine
for his safety
i cannot reveal his identity however
my master gave that's a great tip drew
thank you to assist you in any way i can
i'm not telling you to trust me however
i'll let chad chat decide the ending
the gourd of medicinal water you possess
you guys want shura ending or the real
ending a creation of mine i am a doctor
i think a lot of people here haven't
even played the game so
i don't they probably don't even know
what it is
yes
it was intended for lord kuro but guys
there's no builds in this game or
actually there is kind of
you can update you can upgrade your
you can upgrade walls
but you can't even after being empty get
a build you will find it full again
after a short rest yes see i want to do
real ending is there a way to improve it
like severance
so we get the last boss fight yes
medicinal waters flow from gourd seeds
monk i don't i don't want to talk about
the monk yet the volume of these
medicinal waters if you find any
bring them to me is there ever a variety
in weapons
is this no good seed there's two weapons
and there's there's shinobi arts there's
uh prosthetics
you'll see
will increase
maximum gourd healing increase strange
medicine is it strange
i don't take any offense to that if it's
effective the headless ape ending is for
celebration
whether it's strange or not that's what
my mentor dogen taught me i see
thank you nuts any
i don't use the prosthetics either
either very much i i really don't
oh
did i hear the ringing of a chime it was
probably this bell i mean come on guys
like that that looks good right there
huh bell hold any significance for you
if it does
talk to the sculptor he is quite
knowledgeable when it comes to buddha
strength build
all right but
all right i should have two gourd seeds
now
why do i only have one or do i need to
rust
you gotta
you guys need to remind me to actually
physically rest
because you you know eldon ring you just
had to sit down
in this game you had you have to like
do the thingy
also
i can't just run around i have to use
these to travel to places
so let's go
to
stairway
are you gonna do more lore videos based
on the translations of daniel almost or
do you believe they're fake i have no
idea like reddit just
absolutely annihilated daniel so i just
stopped i have completely stopped
looking at reddit because it's always
just dumb
like of people arguing about certain
[ __ ] and i'm just over it
so
probably not because all those people on
reddit are like well daniel doesn't know
any latin it's like bro
i don't know
very subtle stealth there
[Music]
beautiful
you didn't see me
did this guy just throw a rock at me dog
i'm pretty sure i hear the big guy
behind me and i'm a little upset
spaghetti about it
i'm over this guy
oh my god
why can't i jump please get up there
stop it
okay
we have really got to get used to
everything going on here
no guns
guns are cringe
this boss is annoying
oh you know what i should do hold on
hold on
speed run
speed run
do that now we're closer
now we're closer to potentially dying
over and over again foggers
i'll ask this uh before we go any
further but you guys like snakes you
guys
hopefully you're not afraid of snakes
that's all i'll say
we got reichard coming up next
i need this guy to attack me so i can
deflect
[Music]
there we go
stop with the banging
thank you
[Music]
oh
all right here we go
i don't know what i'm doing
okay
[Music]
all right let's let's both get a little
bit back
[Music]
nope
stop it
cringe
yeah let me let me use mimic here real
quick
[Music]
[Music]
now we're in the flow guys
there it is
that's that
that right there is why i love this game
it's like once you get into that flow of
the fight
it becomes like this
like this dance
like you just start seeing when they're
gonna attack you just time it right just
knock that [ __ ] out of the way
so good
the rhythm
is awesome
okay actually rested
so we're gonna see uh pray to reichard
real quick
yeah flow state true cool
literal flow state
that's probably why i liked rocket
league so much at one point it was like
a flow state
don't look
don't look
you didn't see
nothing
keep looking over there just keep
staring over in that direction
okay
by the way i uninstalled rocket league
again
it's like yeah
boring
this is fine we're fine
totally fine guys
just ignore the giant snake
ignore
my guy's blind dog
blind af
oh
you ready for the worst sound ever
run
you won't let me jump
please
mommy
this is cringe
what
what's happening
i get i have to look up there
you know that's unfortunate
it wouldn't let me look up there dude
oh
all right we're fine everything's fine
that went completely according to plan
are you horny yet chad
okay
are you guys ready for the best voice
acting
ever
who's ready for it
the best voice acting you've all ever
heard in your life
hey thank you esther for becoming a
member again for two months i appreciate
it thank you
thank you very much
damn this looked good
only good voice in english okay
you guys ready for this
my name
it's touring
[Applause]
[Music]
couldn't be worse of a start actually
i
don't know what's happening right now be
honest
i'm dead
it's hyena or not yet loretta
oh oh
i see
that's that's what we're doing
we're gonna have to do this again i feel
wrecking that booty wrecking that booty
okay
his name is for it
what stop running away from me
okay way better deflections
good good good
see if we can do this with absolutely no
health at all
it's leonard i've had a lot of people
in my uh recent video where i talked
about radon say that it is leonard
and whoever said it's leonard is stupid
i'm like wait
i was like wait
but at that point i think people are
just trying to confuse me
so
i don't think it matters
what it is
at least we got to hear the voice line
again
actually i [ __ ] it up
why did i get hit
[Music]
i'm hitting deflect
hello
i'm throwing stacking
i'm hitting deflect bro
did he recover his roots
there we go
there we go
better better better
i'm not eating i'm trying i'm doing my
[Music]
i i don't
okay
there we go
never seen that attack i don't think
all right split
he was standing on his horse that was
kind of cool
but he still is
where are you going dog
what the heck
i don't know what's up where i can't
deflect that
so i know you can't
okay
come on jake
[Music]
finish it off cringe
nice
w
kinda that was pretty [ __ ] bad
some of those attacks i couldn't
remember how to uh deflect this is bad
wait so i didn't really lose my stuff
did i i don't think that happens in this
game
i always feel bad for the horse yeah the
horse always just like shoves you off of
him
and disappears along with him
okay so now we can enhance
our attack power because we have a
memory of gyobu
so every big boss that we beat that way
we can get the remembrance like
remembrances and get stronger like we
just attack better
reflection of strength
choose which extraordinary photo to face
so i can go back and fight this boss
anytime i want to
which is kind of kind of cool dude
um
okay
you lose xp but you got unseen aid oh
right right right
how do i um
so i can enhance my skills whenever i
want
no
no shot right
gilbus
voiced by troy baker is that true
fight boss again
no
some reason i thought this was a
premiere of a secure video not a stream
no this is a stream
i'll probably make the stream
into a video
would you guys want the edited version
oh wait we gotta go to uh
yeah we gotta go to this guy over here
real quick
you get the skill tree if you return to
the sculptor and talk to him okay we'll
do that next
i was wondering how i get that
wolf is voiced by the voice actor and
charles in red dead too
cool i like charles
oh yes
this is technically eachine right
[Music]
another red
but those eyes
a starving wolf before i kill you
tell me your name tell me your name okay
it's wolf
no name to give you should not be all
the same
you need to give him firecrackers you
just want me to use firecrackers however
your left arm
a prosthetic
tell me your name
thanks fictional that's it
the sub count has been exploding lately
which has been which means
secure
that is what i shall name you he just
named us
are you
ah your name this night
care to hunt some rats with me what rats
could i have killed the rat and then ran
over here
to make it faster
i think i could have all kinds of rats
out there and they must be cut down
every last one of them oh okay you have
a talent for killing
allow me to help you hone that talent
what'll it be
will you hunt rats with me
okay very well excellent you'll need
this if you're with me secure
rat description so there's those little
uh trolls
he calls them rats the face of a rat
and where it makes its home
go and kill it if you do
i will give you something that will aid
you in battle
he gives us a really cool
like battle arts right
rin
yobu is voiced by sarah jessica parker
wow that's really cool
you guys totally aren't [ __ ] with me
right
okay we're gonna go up here we're gonna
kill i think we can just kill one rat
and go back
which is this guy
and now we run back
easy as that
this guy pretty much runs just as fast
as we do on torrent
in eldon ring
it's speedy
and it's gone
looks like you've caught yourself
somebody only takes one yes i knew you
had a talent for killing wonderful
here's your reward
thank you the mario movie
the ways of the ashina blade it's our
school there's a seed on top of the
tower but there are no hard and fast
rules you just win your battles no there
is no stamina in this game
endless stamina
style i hope it can be of assistance
with your rat hunting
and most of all your own battles you've
yet to fight
okay you guys are just saying stuff now
i appreciate it thank you very much
i will say the inner parts of most areas
in this game are very dark
and maybe i'm just old and can't see
and you guys can uh
[Music]
you know blame me for being old
but i can't [ __ ] see dawg
oh hello
oh
you survived of course that accursed
finally a corpse i take it
that change is nothing you know
there'll be more wars there'll be more
corpses i'm not that old seated hatred
will run wild where's all that hatred
get a light
haven't you ever wondered
guess not
guess you haven't that's why i pity you
and i pitied him
man's not eating his carrots okay
don't you guys think it's dark
dark as [ __ ]
this is fine
i can see this
this is great
so there's you said there's a pellet or
a gourd seed on top of this tower
i don't know how to get up there yet oh
god we're fine
uh that's okay we're gonna go beat up
the bowl now
which by the way the bowl is basically
the falling star beast from elden ring
a hundred percent we can climb up inside
oh
that's okay we're gonna go beat up the
bullet
speed run
oh and we need to go back
i already forgot that we needed to go
back we can beat the ball like this
we're fine
speed run whoops
and
falling star beast
dog i think you should be focused on
this
oh
that was not
at all what i wanted to do there just
saying
okay
okay
that's fine
all right i need to get in my flow again
we are not in flow state
here we go
he's getting annihilated
keep it going
i
knew that was gonna happen
i knew it
there's literally no flow for bull
yeah i mean if you get behind him
you're
good
worst boss a hundred percent
do a dark souls one play through
as i'm playing sakura let me just let me
you know what let me just turn off the
game let me let's go play dark souls one
right guys
just for yoda
because he said to
so you goober ass
is this the first time i've double died
your death is not your fate i don't
think so
just yet
well hey at least i can get my skills
rot essence
somewhere a pained cough rings out
continuously
the man who coughs zealously sculpts
statues of buddha to avoid being
consumed by the building flames
owning this item reduces one's chances
of receiving unseen aid
just got that okay
skyrim
no what is it seems to me your battle
since has returned
you're more like a shinobi than before
if only a little take this
okay so we got that what is it shinobi
techniques yeah we can do skills now are
fighting techniques that cannot be
basically scarlet rot
whether you make use of them or not is
up to you chanel we aren't the only ones
with their own fighting techniques
listen guys i can tell yoda is under the
age of 16. i can just tell bro
if he's not
then as a little sussy baca but i found
one hey
i'm gonna make fun of them a little bit
said before that your prosthetic arm was
a fang but by fitting shinobi tools to
your arm
you'll be able to change the form of
that thing thick shields break them into
splitters hey all these buddha statues
are kind of like disturbing from afar
fitting more devices means more ways to
slay your enemies if there's someone
that needs killing there's a proper way
to kill them that's all there is to it
hmm
seems you know like the dung eaters
effects
i should call myself
so that's why i say scarlet rot dragon
rod scarlet rot
present shinobi prosthetic fit new
prosthetic tool
loaded shuriken
i think it just shoots off shuriken
right that's pretty cool
okay tools aided open equipment use
prosthetic tools switch prosthetic pool
okay
boom
hurricane well you need these things to
use them
spirit emblems got it okay
got it got it got it got i got it
we're good
all right
let's uh
where were we
i think we could only be at the castle
pay for membership he's not a member
the only fromsoft game with real-life
religion
oh you mean buddha
my understanding
well yeah it is never mind
scratch what i was about to say
[Music]
i love the music bro it's so good
okay
speed run tactics yet again
let's get this [ __ ] out of here
great start
okay let me get behind you there we go
okay i thought i was behind you i was
wrong it was incorrect
probably should use one of these
oh my god
what's sad is this is just a bull who's
scared of the fire that's going on on
his head right now kind of sad
i didn't like where i was so i got out
of there
nice
can i use prosthetics on you
yeah
what just happened
oh
die
oh wait he goes crazy here right
this fall
good night sweet prince
i would no i wouldn't
oh this is so french
come on bro
okay okay
good night sweet prince
see that that's what i want to do the
first time but now it's it's just weird
okay never mind
never mind
oh no i don't have mikiri counter yet
okay thank god
[Music]
what
what
this game is as hard as i remember you
can die to such random [ __ ]
okay
heroes never
heroes never die
god
like how you act all sad about it then
your character does a [ __ ] musty
flick execution on the ball
good night sweet prince
yeah
exactly
okay where's mercury counter boom
instantly already
beating the game there in instantaneous
w
just having that
okay now our health is a little bit
larger
we have a bit a little bit of a larger
um
it's one of the finger
have you readers of the senpai temple
have you heard of the finger maidens
a very special holy person lives in that
place
go on
this woman was voiced by chris pratt
that makes sense i can definitely hear
that
cringe
all right
um
where do you guys want to go do you guys
want to go up this way and go fight uh
gennichiro
or do you want to go to the monk palace
where do you want to go
up to you i don't really care where we
go i'm going to rest though
i'll fight in ichiro right now if i'm a
kiri counter i'm good
senpu
have you tried finger butthole
okay let's go
we'll go monk
wait i want to eavesdrop i heard you
were the one that put the armor on that
big bugger another conveniently placed
conversation
it was a damned awful job but it looks
like it paid off didn't it he already
had a huge frame and massive strength
and you just made him near impervious to
blades that is true but
he doesn't like that armor and he sure
didn't like me putting it on him when a
fight happens it might come off easier
than you think
we get a key from this guy right
gatehouse key
oh what was that my guy
little bit off there
yeah were they talking about robert
robert
that's gonna be really weird if you
don't know what the hell i'm talking
about
like what is this guy on robber
speed run
there's a merchant
oh i should have rested
since when do you come in here you
always stay outside dog
all right
goodbye
i'm out
[Music]
i have never thoroughly investigated
this area besides this guy right here
what are you doing here
of all places
yeah
i don't know what i'm doing here are you
perhaps a shinobi
always say nothing chat always
my you are a talkative one aren't you
in that case i don't wish to waste any
more of your time
good day yeah it really does have
nothing
besides gross ass bugs
those guys alive
uh nope
nope nope nope
headless monkey okay
y'all are just saying who people are
voiced by
every time i look at chat
look you can swim in this game though
oh wow
[Music]
is anything up here
akko sugar
uh
like coin purse
gun powder
not fair not fair
mercury counter [ __ ]
imagine using guns in this world
uh imagine
this guy thinks it's bloodborne
[Applause]
get mode
absolutely mowed upon
fall in the water
brutal
brutal
they'd have guns in japan at this time i
know i'm just complaining
and i need you to complain along with me
okay
guns are good in bloodborne
tell you perry
i mean they're obviously working on this
game when they were first
not when they were first probably
mid development of elden ring they
probably released this game i wonder
like
yes
hello
i don't remember this
that sounded like
the parrot
you you pump pump a rump from dark souls
3
sounded exactly the same
oh yeah you talked to this thing
[Music]
i wonder like was the team that worked
on sakiro different from the team that
worked on elden ring it had to have been
i wonder if they were working on them
both at the same time
how long does it take to beat this game
depends how good you are
but if you do
is it pickle p
pickle p pump a rump
i just remember the pump will pump a
rump
okay so the monks here are
[Music]
for your bad
it is the least we can do
no i have never played shadow of the
colossus should i play that
i've heard a lot about shadow of the
colossus but i've never actually played
the game holy [ __ ] this is pretty
oh my god
a 4k monitor by the way 4k monitor
4k
just so you guys know
4k
i would like shadow of the colossus
i bet i would
what can i play it on
what's up fitzy
my uh
he's so slow
this guy just block a sword with his own
hands
what a legend
all right
you got some reach
nice all right you're confusing
does he do a sweep
[Music]
is that material
answered my own question
jake are you standing no i'm sitting
down in my chair
i'm actually kind of sweaty
our air conditioning is currently not on
it's not working currently
so i have a fan blowing on my backside
it's not doing a lot
oh i ain't [ __ ] around with this
peter on tactics
speed run
okay good
good good good
some crickets
dude i hate bugs
i hate bugs bro
is that guy being ridden around by
crickets
broken sugar ceramic shard
i'm out of there bro nope
hey
yeah i'm gonna have to cancel that and
come back
because the music is just overshadowing
what she's saying
wow okay
let's go back
i actually just tried to double jump
like i had torrent like i'm not even
kidding
i've played way too much elden ring
lately
i just want to talk to the old lady
again man
leave me alone
the masculine urge to sit in a cloud of
wafted ball sweat are you
what
the [ __ ]
what happens when you don't get lean
what fruits of the serpent yes
there are two kinds
one is fresh
the other is dried it's over there the
fresh one is over there
over the cliff
they mummify themselves where you'll
find it
fresh
what are you talking about
something troubling you rice for me
that's the way
rice i say if something troubles your
mind bless me with rice anytime
nice rhyme
oh we need to find her some rhyme
rhyme we need to find her some rice
so when we find some rice we come find
her
all the swords born are in their own
right elden ring bloodborne skiro dark
souls are all so different from each
other and they have uh evaluated
standalone art pieces totally agree
liberty
i wasn't i wasn't entirely sure
because i have not played another souls
game until after i've played eldon ring
so i've only played elden ring the last
four months right so i was curious of
how i would feel
about these games
uh after playing elden ring and i can
say that it feels just as good as it did
back then
i don't [ __ ] around with these guys
nope
i just know there's a lot of parts in
this game that i just fly right past
to get to a boss fight
here we go
okay actually physically rest there we
go
i think i can get a skill actually yeah
i have two
ichimanji's really good
yeah ichimanji's great
that's when you know it's damn good
yeah i mean all these games are good i
am curious of how i'd feel about dark
souls
like dark souls 1 maybe even dark souls
3 i wouldn't feel the same about
i'm not sure
i'll have to go play them
whoa
little rats
what is that
why is that guy just a legend
how do i do my ichimanji i don't
remember
i remember
this guy's a god
what is happening
who is this guy
oh my god
he had so many different attacks dude
that was awesome okay
like the first guy i just annihilated
and that guy was like
a lord
right over your noggin
all right you guys ready for honestly
one of the coolest bosses in the game
we're gonna do this with uh
limited resources
[Music]
oh wow that got me good
yes
can't hurt this guy physically
oh bro
my son will receive the water he
destroys your posture yeah but i destroy
his posture
i don't think you can't hurt that guy's
help
so we're gonna have to do some other
stuff
as you'll see
i've never beaten dark souls 2 which is
why i really want to play it on stream
that might be a journey though
we'll see
dark souls 2 is metal's favorite game
that's what i've heard that's what she
tells me
no point in even attacking him
uh-huh you guys think of what i'm
thinking
i love the environmental cues that this
fight gives you
to be like so can't hurt him right
look at the windows great game isn't
that interesting
all right
it's the ground
that is so cool dude
i love it man
you gotta wait a little while and then
you hear the bang
beautiful beautiful
i'd say i've died a few times but like
i'm kind of
kind of flowing through the game
currently
kind of flowing
that would be an awful way to die
yeah
i don't care though
okay don't have those don't have any
battle memories
i can't fight him again if i wanted to
that kind of sucks
i think if the souls games are hard
killing the nine breaker in armored
court
games is next here i've never played
armored core i know that's from software
is like
one of their first series right
so pretty dude i can't wait till we get
to the um
is it called the forbidden temple
listen we want that stuff which is why i
killed the fish i know they're pretty
but hey it had to be done
all right guys
hi guys yep yep
now do i go to the monkeys i think i go
monkeys now
i know there's a boss behind me oh my
god
sorry i gotta appreciate how good a game
looks when i see it dude
this is nice
i gotta appreciate it man
i think it's actually easier to just run
through this area
yeah 4k by the way 4k
yep
and goes sugar
ungo
under sugar yeah we're running
i probably should have mentioned this
but i did used to attempt speed running
this game which is probably why i'm
doing this like crazy routing
i didn't do it for very long
the final boss
opening doors
and they won't come in here
they'll just stay right back over there
yay
oh it's our boy
yeah what up
children
of the rejuvenating waters i have to
fight in ichiro first
no we haven't seen lady butterfly yet
she's the only one left
she must be lonely
trapped in that room
by herself what's up terenator how are
you he must be so lonely
who's he talking about
you there
who are you what business do you have
um you have centipedes growing out of
your face dog
ask about special holy person i'm told
that a special holy person lives here
remarkably hey 4k by the way guys that
would be the child i imagine
she's not here anymore
it's my fault this game needs a remaster
i mean clearly it looks so bad
needs a remaster came out three years
ago
needs to be needs a
remastered yeah let me pause the stream
for conan so you can go take a dump
i have a favor to ask of you the child
wanted to know
the reason lady butterfly i believe is
optional yeah
youtube compression kind of looking bad
honestly
does it look bad for other people
is that right card uh
yes
anyway
let's travel to
you guys said i have to go uh
bill genichiro right okay
just me i think
yeah i think it looks pretty good
why are we spamming my name incorrectly
ggt
space jake what is your favorite from
software game
i've been thinking about this
here let's talk about this for a minute
is eldering is elden ring your guys's
favorite from software game
no i'm not jewish why would it matter if
i were
well i'm sorry is elden ring your
favorite from software game
because
i don't think it's mine it it was
when i first played it but the more i
think about it
i think i like
dark souls 3 better hold on
they got dark outside so that got dark
i might i might say bloodborne
might might legitimately be better than
elden ring
like as one of my favorites
obvi like obviously dark souls 3 is
gonna dark souls yeah dark souls 3 is
going to be my
prop i would say dark souls 3 is
probably my personal favorite actually
because it was the first one i ever
played i played all the games in a
really weird order
uh i played dark souls 3 dark souls 1
dark souls 2
bloodborne sequiero elden ring so
yeah i'm kind of struggling with that
too myself playing this game terrinator
because of just four months
i'm not surprised dark souls 3 is your
favorite
yeah i i love that like do not get me
wrong elden ring is [ __ ] incredible i
absolutely love it but i don't the more
i've played it
the more i've been like okay so
it's an open world game and i don't
think
i'm like a mega fan of open world games
like i kind of like this where it's sort
of open world but it has like a linear
path that you need to go on to progress
which eldon rings kind of like that it's
just [ __ ]
huge
and then the repeated bosses of elden
ring as well kind of kind of you know
it does have that effect over time we
were just kind of like
[Music]
do i really want to fight this
uh
godskin again not not really bro like
yeah hopefully i'm making sense do i
have to go to emma yeah let me go to
emma first
because i like open world games but not
to play like
i don't know how to put this because i
absolutely love elden ring like it's one
of the best games ever made but it is my
favorite from software game i think is a
different question
right undyne samurai training material
okay yeah
i believe i have to talk to emma
have you seen the sculptor lately yes no
i've never played breath of the wild all
i know is i don't have a switch
that the dragon's heritage can bestow
the power i agree ludwig
it is a
big strength ordinary power and a
weakness
leads to stagnation
which will eventually reach a point
where it overflows
this causes those who do not have the
power to become sick
i don't have a problem
with reused assets
in elden ring i don't think that's a
problem
like when people say it's a it's a bad
thing that they reuse like animations
from dark souls or dark souls 3 or
bloodborne in elden ring
you don't got to fix what ain't broke
like if that stuff works and it looks
good with the weapon that you're using
just use it absolutely they do that it's
their own
it's what they've made right
so i don't have a problem with that at
all and i don't even think it's an
argument to call a game
not as good as
you know
give it a downgrade with that you know
what i'm saying
man i had two of those sweet
does that make sense i feel like i
didn't explain that very well but
yeah reused uh cop like copy and paste
bosses yeah that's an issue
but reused assets that's not a problem
for me
can we ban colton this guy's talking
about
this such dumb [ __ ]
take your racism somewhere else you
weirdo
here
i don't even know if they're here
in racism dude imagine
okay
100 makes sense it's just it i've been
thinking of this lately
right it's been on my mind recently of
like i think i've
another big part of it is i think
i'm
a little bit
burnt out on eldon ring
like i have 500 hours in elden ring or
four i think it's 400 not 500 400 hours
in ellen ring it's a lot of time in four
months it's an hour 100 hours a month
playing one game obviously trying to get
content out and stuff like that that
definitely changes stuff up for me
i i definitely burnt myself out a bit i
still love it though
do not do not get it twisted
that i don't like it
yeah i think i met i think i beat the
game eight times now
it's a lot and we beat all of the game
the whole thing
so
we beat uh we did hundred percent play
through just a couple weeks ago so
is he whistling for me
yes i know
master finichiro is waiting is he not i
will return to the top of oshima castle
you never completed elden ring
yeah
i think
before i'm definitely gonna make a video
on my points of like why elden ring is
kind of dying
um that's kind of my next video idea
just to have a conversation about it
because elden ring is not
dying
it was uh
it's i'm sure you are all aware already
people are beating the game and they're
overwhelmed with how big it is and they
don't want to play it again
we go now
to risk our lives for lord issuing
how do you see me dog
how do you see me
it size tires me i i agree i i think
that's
that goes for a lot of people
the [ __ ] which of the games would you
recommend to an enthusiastic noob
um
have you played eldon ring
just out of curiosity like did you are
you first introduced to the games
through alden ring
i love sakiro but i wouldn't recommend
it to a noob
this game's hard as balls
i'd say dark souls 3
if you're uh considering yourself a noob
i'd say dark souls 3 or elden ring if
you haven't played it
what is this
that is an interesting attack
hey are you guys ready for this do you
see that guy up on that kite right there
there's a dude there
now i want everyone to get your
whoo
who's ready okay type out
w000 as many o's as you want whoa
and just get ready for it dude to start
i i love this dude
well that
that hurt
immediately dies
yeah i got wiped there that's that's
okay it happens for the best of us
that guy hey that guy had a good time
doing what he loved right
oh [ __ ] not another one
time to run boys we we don't need to
nope
here we go
they just crash into the ground dude
it's awesome
oh another gourd seed nice
scared the [ __ ] out of me first time i
played it too dude it it's just so
random right
so incredibly random
okay
so this area right here guys is one of
the most annoying areas in the game at
least for me
so
here's what you do
you run through
you open the door
gonna take a right
we're gonna go up top over here
through the roof
run right through all these people
and go right here
[Music]
try and get a rest off before this guy
gets over here
and completely ignore that area
that's how you skip that entire spot
look at that
look at that
we're so good at the game
what is this
uh
excuse
the me waters that is what it is called
are you telling me that this is ashina's
secret weapon
again i i used to speed run this game so
i know what area
excuse me what areas to avoid and just
like be like okay this isn't worth it
it springs from the dragon's blood does
it not yes lady emma
i do not believe the dragon's blood is
sacred
not at all
yelling increases your power by 25
that is
that is true okay here we go
this boss can either be super easy
or super ridiculously hard based on how
good my deflecting is
this guy can insta kill me
or i can insta kill his ass
we go find out
today
[Music]
not bad
good start
[Music]
i forgot
and i'm dead just like that i'm [ __ ]
dead all right
let me heal once
[ __ ] off
freaking draw bro
[Music]
nice
w first try
first time i played this game i was
stuck on this guy for three hours
i think i had to quit i had to come back
the next day
reed hanging scroll of an old battle
okay
that's
okay ooh that's how i get lightning
reversal is from that
glad i picked that up because we're
gonna need that like right now
did i stab him in the armpit oh i'm
sorry
oof let me go rest real quick because
we're about to fight genjiro
i think eldon rings popularity is kind
of annoying here i love learning about
its lore and all the moog is the best
but i think i people have to calm down
not like a loving game is bad or
anything
why is it annoying though
oh cool
why is that annoying to you
hey i'm calming god i'm not a dog
um okay they're there um
yeah why is that annoying
i love alden ring's popularity finally
from software getting the recognition
they deserve
yeah i can't i can't enjoy people
enjoying things that's just annoying to
me
it's a wonder he is still with us
a miracle
is that so
the casuals are annoying why why does it
even matter like let people enjoy the
game
divine air i'll ask you once more what
could they possibly do to annoy you
it's it's a pretty weird take yeah i
agree
no you're a forehead
that's what i would tell him if i was a
lord i'd go
i cannot do that no
you're a forehead
you think you're a five head your
victory that day you're actually a two
head
and then you get sad
to take me home
for he
is my shinobi
it doesn't stress me out at all time
i don't give a [ __ ]
lord i have come for you
paul is the most popular guy i know
actually
dude i kind of want an arm like that
like it's just cool
i'm gonna get a tattoo sleeve on my left
arm i'm excited
[Music]
i'm starting my designs to get my
i've always wanted a left arm tattoo
sleeve
the dragons
i'm gonna plan it out and get uh
it'll be like years
of getting tattoos but it'll be cool all
right let's go
[Music]
little ichimanji in there
ah
[Music]
little mikiri
nice
absolutely owning you currently sir
owned
that's all i have to say about that
[Music]
normally i would um like not want to go
into that but i had enough posture to
deal with it if i had less posture i
wouldn't have done that
oh i just need to deflect those that
would have been way easier if i did okay
okay
nice
i had enough stamina to deal with that
that's okay just let him flail around
like an idiot
oh okay that was weird
i'll take it
it's gonna heal you off
get my healies on again
[Music]
i wish there was a little bit of light
in this room
uh i had enough to deal with it i just
don't wanna oh okay little
little mix up there kind of cool
that's so awesome
no we did the sweep
i wasn't ready for it
nope not enough stamina to deal with
that enough posture
nice
ah
was doing so well
[Music]
he's trying to break my posture i see
sir
i got a deal for sure
yeah you can't reach that far dog
you're just not good enough for that
very nice
we're gonna back off this time however
we'll do a little arrow get our posture
back
nice
okay i didn't think he would roll into
an attack
what the heck was that
all right
good start ish
could be could be better you know
three phases by the way impressive
of the divine air these bosses look way
more time consuming more methodical
no it's uh yeah definitely do not answer
to a different lord this this game's all
about deflecting like we said it has
nothing to do with health
heresy oh should we make drew a mod
i'm down
[Music]
i got you i will cease any manner of
strength it's definitely a rhythm game
very different from elden ring
behold homeboy
so moy
i promise to use my powers wisely as he
bans [ __ ] everybody in the chat
really
wait how do you deflect again lightning
i dodged it somehow
i don't remember how to do it
jump r1 that's what i was doing here
it's not working
it's weird i'm dodging it though
weird
um i probably could have dealt with that
first try
slice them up
i'm using uh ishimanji
oh we got a memory
first try genichiro are we really still
this good at the game i mean
[Music]
miyazaki could do a game like metroid
prime justice
haven't we met her why does why is he
even like
oh he thought he was with him okay i get
it is this
the rejuvenating scratch valley
oh that's creepy actually what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
no i don't have a playstation anymore
for her
couldn't i do play
playstation now
on pc
hmm
resurrection
okay we can resurrect dogs
i like star wars fall in order
it's a good game
it's okay
that guy's still alive
we're after i have to fight him later
what's the skill are you using i already
answered you
i already answered you you should have
been listening you forehead
imagine not listening to the streamer
when you comment and he answers your
question then you say dude answer my
question again bro
ichimanji though
okay
i want these uh
no i don't know what they're i forget if
they're here or up here i'm pretty sure
they're up here
mid-air to well i want that yeah
ah
it's not what i wanted
oh none of these are what i wanted
that's what we need here
both of these
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
those are big okay gennichiro
using your ears
ichimondi ichimanji these nuts bro
okay sorry sorry sorry um
oh let me mod drew hold up
drew
speak okay there we go
mod
drew has been around since i streamed
valorant on youtube
that tells you something
that really tells you something man
i've managed to fulfill my speaking of
nuts congrats on your sponsor thank you
i wish the rick video was doing better
it's definitely not doing well views
wise
but it's okay why
it's to be expected
has no desire to use remember the v10s
which was a good idea by the way cole he
tried it's a good idea
correct the message i found in the well
that was your doing also your lore
videos remind me of a less somber vati
video very informative and enjoy to
watch i'm glad you like it man i think
you'd like to see lord i'm glad he's
downstairs
i definitely see myself as kind of a
a goofball
more than a lore guy
but
yeah
the rick video was really good it's just
uh interest in elden ring has gone
completely down
i remember that one rl tournament where
i banned like a hundred people
yeah we held a thousand dollars no it
was like 1400 rocket league tournament
right
and we banned
we may have banned hundreds of people
that day like it was really bad you
should do v bucks giveaways
um no but you can go by uh go buy some
manscaped right guys check the link in
the description
get yourself one of these it lights up
you can shave your nut sack
also comes with ball toner if you use
code agt you get 20 off
and you get two free gifts
which is a travel bag
and boxer briefs that say manscaped on
them so you should go do that check out
the link in the description
i would like it if they kept sponsoring
me so
yeah
or go watch the rick video that helps me
out a ton too
what's ball toner it makes your balls
smell good dude
if there are any girls in chat who are
into guys
they'll tell you that they don't want
smelly balls bro they want
nice smelly
balls i have come for you my lord yes
well yeah if you get all sweaty
helps go we must leave
wolf
my blood
the blood of the dragon causes men to
become undying
nobody wants smelly balls yes my lord i
wish to save you already bought the
performance kit as soon as your video
dropped thank you cole you're the man
dude thanks
the immortal dude
the rejuvenating waters
the dragon rot the scarlet rot
to the point that they no longer no no
no no even if you shower
it still doesn't smell good
your balls are just gonna smell wet
or like soap
this is like cologne for your nuts dude
that's cool
obey the iron code and protect kuro or
help crow
what should we do
my natural musk is quite quite alluring
i'm sure
i'm just saying
that you know
hey buy what you want all right
i don't care
iron code help iron code his same person
said iron code
is this the forehead logo no
iron code
help hero
does it matter
i forget
give jake your money if you guys really
want to help me out
financially
go watch the rick video
go watch it three or four times i would
appreciate that
that video is doing not like how is it
doing actually
i don't know
i haven't checked
it's a 9 out of 10 in my last few videos
it's at 31 000 views in the first day
which is pretty
hey if you told me three months ago that
i would be disappointed in 30 000 views
in 24 hours i would be laughing at you
so all is well
but
i'd like for it to do better
and i think it will eventually get there
it's just like interest in eldon ring
has gone so down lately that people will
watch it eventually but they're not like
actively looking it up on youtube right
now which is totally expected and
totally fine
totally fine um i'm going to obey the
iron code not to protect you i think he
he says something to convince me you're
entrusted to me how many times have you
died and come back to life for my sake
not that many actually three times yeah
two three times a number so large that
it cannot be counted as it was for the
purpose of defending my lord the number
does not matter i do not wish to bind
you you don't have to taranator
i appreciate that though
join me in my quest to sever the ties of
immortality because there's there's
really nothing you can do about interest
in something going down
on youtube
um like eldon ring i think has ran its
course until dlc comes out don't you
guys think
too late the deeds done why i appreciate
that thank you
yeah yeah
if we are seeking to sever the immortal
ties
i know a good place to start wolf look
at this
so much it can't be counted that's some
pretty [ __ ] funny dialogue
we've actually only died like two three
times dragon tears first time i played
the game though
we died uh we died a lot
we died a
to lot the dragon's heritage but
the divine realm
are you a scrub wolf
that incense burner over there it
belonged to a
person of interest take a look why can't
they [ __ ] tell me anything
is there something special about it no
i'm told that long ago there was another
divine air yeah it burnt out until we
play it on a 4k monitor
this incense burner belonged to him it
looks pretty damn good on a 4k monitor
i'll tell you guys that right now long
time ago apparently
wrapped in the air yeah
i would say divine realm or i'll let him
talk supposedly the words he left behind
you're saying the scent of the
fountainhead
is the key to reaching the divine realm
that is my belief
wolf
let us discover the truth together
i i think if i'm getting burnt out on
eldon ring then i would say most people
are getting burned out on the ring like
i have every reason in the world to just
keep playing it keep making content for
it
uh whatever the case may be
for
my
job or whatever right
but
you know it's been four months
with no new content so people are gonna
get burnt they're gonna get bored that's
fine we gotta play some other stuff
until dlc comes out and as soon as dlc
drops we're right back on that train
everybody's gonna be back on that train
as well it's gonna be
this is how it works that's
to be expected as to how we begin our
search i am certain some of lord
takerow's books remain in this castle
books that he collected in order to find
the divine realm i will search for them
in addition to finding a way yeah i
think so
but everyone's already kind of doing
that like the uh randomizer mods
stuff like that talk to ishii if anyone
knows the answer it is him wolf come
with me
oh elden ring has a ton of replayability
just when you
it's so big
that
it's kind of like when you start a new
character
or a new
play through
you're kind of
it's kind of overwhelming
i would say is that a good word for it
maybe overwhelming where you're like man
do i really want to run all the way
there to get that boss do i really want
to do this to that so i have so i can go
over here like there's a lot of stuff
that you have to do to do certain things
but you have the choice to go wherever
you want
it you know it's kind of hard to explain
what about the convergence mod for dark
souls 3. i have never tried that
that could be really fun drew that's a
great idea
very true
it's cool to first play through maybe
the second if you're going for 100 but
then it gets harder to get back into
each time yep
i think so
like the um
this probably goes for most souls games
but
like
come tell me if you guys feel the same
way
first time you're playing the game
everything's new to you so everything's
exciting no matter where you're
traveling to you're going to this area
and then you you you come across
something really cool um something you
didn't know about before
when you when you know every
most of the stuff in the game
when you've experienced what there is to
experience once
maybe twice
even with replayability that elden ring
has and all of these games do where you
can make a different build
you can make a different type of
character
there's a it's overwhelming
to have all that to do
right
like
especially if you completely restart a
new character and you're weak as hell at
the beginning i guess you can always
like go back to ranala and get respect
to have a different kind of build
without having to go through everything
again
um but it's still
overwhelming and then that experience
that first experience you had
when you're
going to that when you're first
experiencing that really cool boss
that
that's that feeling is now gone because
you experienced it which honestly is a
really good problem to have for a game
right like that experience was so
[ __ ] good the first time it's really
cool the second time but after that
you're kind of like well i kind of know
what to expect
it's still really cool
but
it's it's only gonna last about one or
two playthroughs and then it's gonna
it's gonna drop off you know what i'm
saying
and that can be said with any game
exactly
except
for multiplayer games because you're
gonna go into you're competing with
other players
in a competitive mode like call of duty
or valorent or like apex legends
fortnight whatever it is
um you're you're competing against other
players so you're technically having a
different experience every time you play
the game
in the same setting
i think it's definitely a huge downgrade
to eldon ring that the pvp community is
one
uh
really hard to get into
like it's just kind of annoying to get
into pvp in elden ring
um
two it's completely unbalanced from my
understanding i haven't really touched
it all that much but uh from what i've
heard from people who are in the pvp
community for elden ring it's it's
unbalanced is [ __ ]
everyone's using uh these super
overpowered weapons that
just aren't fun to fight against right
so
there's no
multiplayer to keep people going into it
basically all i've heard about with pvp
and elden ring is that it's it's
annoying and it tilts people and they
don't want to do it
arguably apex is the same experience
over and over again he can die that's my
experience because i'm bad
and i think i just don't like battle
royale games i
the thing i hate about apex in all
battle royale games is the 20 [ __ ]
minutes of looting at the beginning i
it's i'm just holding my nut sack
without manscaped in my like to make it
an enjoyable nice smelling experience
i'm just holding my nut sack for 20
[ __ ] minutes to
uh loot for that long and then get in my
first engagement and probably die it's
really annoying dude
and then i gotta do it again i gotta
drop down i gotta loot everything again
like
[ __ ]
you know
duels are fun sometimes like
yeah
that was a pretty good plug there too
yeah
elden rings endings just aren't too
different i mean eldon lord is five
flavors of sonny d i agree with you that
was kind of my first thought when i saw
like the fia ending dung eater
uh elden lord ending they're all kind of
the same thing with a different skin
over the top but then there are some
really cool endings as well
unbalanced and not good in general yeah
most pvp players i know have given up on
eldon ring till the patch or something
to bounce yeah
which is why i mean
can we look it up here
no i don't know why it doesn't let me do
this here
there we go
why is this like this my monitor's all
[ __ ] up but anyway
um
eldon rings
interest like google trends has gone
just completely down
which is that's fine that's to be
expected but there's you know
it's ran its course so my whole point in
talking about this is like we gotta move
on to some other games we gotta move on
to some other content until dlc comes
out and then we're right back on that
[ __ ] train dude because i i honestly
wanna make more content i really do
i want to put out more stuff for you
guys to watch because i love making
content
um
but i mean [ __ ] bro like you guys have
no i like there's a reason vati video
takes a month to make a video i'm just
saying
it's
the work that goes into a lore video is
absolutely unbelievable i'm working more
than i did in any other job i've ever
had which is a good thing
but i mean holy crap
the the research involved making sure
what you're saying is correct unless
you're making like a rick video right
that's just like total
for fun but uh
yeah research writing out the entire
script just you know to make sense uh
get get recorded footage
of everything you need
i can't tell you how many times chat
that i had to go and play through the
entire game
to get a three second clip of the fire
giant because i said the fire giant in
my script
where i have to play through the game
for four hours me speed running through
to get a specific three second clip of
like the fire giant or something
it takes a while to get to that point
it's
it's a lot more work than you guys may
think
um not saying i want to decrease the
quality of my content
but um
i want to make more
content
more games
more ways like i still want to do lore
videos i still but i want to expand it
out there as well
it is so hot in this room
it is ridiculously hot in here
there's no way air is blowing in this
room i'm gonna get some water
i'm gonna be right back but
disgust amongst yourselves
i need water
hello
okay we're back
hmm
okay what are we talking about yep
professional streamer i am the best
streamer i had to go get water what do
you want me to do it's hot in here
he wants to get
okay
uh you can on ps5 just use play share
what
anyway
would be funny to play elden ring on one
of this
oh eternal ring
i don't even know what that is
that was your water side quest it was
great
not as great as my 4k monitor though
when is the merch line drop my sister's
working on it so
whenever she gets it done and we turn it
into
something
uh
real streamers don't get up for water
that is not true every streamer i watch
is constantly not at their computer
how do i get in on the roof there's a
path patrolled by the night jar ninja
it's intended for shinobi but i imagine
that won't be a problem for you i've
heard the night jar you smoke signals
what were we talking about yes
so if you follow their smoke signals we
were talking about content able to reach
lord eachine and you can use this window
to reach the roof
i will do that
yeah we were talking about content
um
yeah
tldr
the short of it i just want to make more
content
for you guys
and
i think there's lots of other games that
we could really enjoy
together
didn't need to follow the smoke trail
here he is
about the divine air's life yeah we'll
do another princess peach stream
that's exclusive for twitch what and it
will stay there forever
sake
my grandson gunichuro was bewitched by
the rejuvenating waters you did well to
put a stop to that for me you have my
things you ever considered the code my
father taught me ah
no we're not doing that again so you're
the son of owl that boy i was pretty
good though during the rebellion
yes and your travels brought you here
you guys miss some of the best content
you've ever seen on twitch but i will
never be returning to that platform
so what do you wish to know
i missed something great the divine
heirs desire is to sever the ties of
immortality i want to know how it can be
done the mortal blade if you had such a
weapon
it may be the key to what you are after
the mortal blade with it
flop
or remove their head
and they wouldn't die
if the stories are we just going to be
modding a bunch of people today
to kill a monster such as that
you'd need the mortal blade new pc is
great
i mean hopefully it looks great it's
it's running the stream right now so
hopefully it looks good
where can the mortal blade be found
where is this mortal blade i've heard
it's held in semport temple however they
say the mortal blade cannot be drawn
what do you mean i am not i didn't
didn't need a good deal it's just here
sir
i just got one of the nzxt computers who
knows what those degenerates are doing
shut away up there in the mountains
there aren't any decent roads leading
there
twitch has gone evil some streamers seem
to be leaving the platform i just don't
like it
yeah i got a pre-built
offering
i just wanted it quick since the other
one broke on me
jesus
guys downing that [ __ ] stuff
by the way you guys ever had sake it's
strong
you do cross blades did you not
to put it simply he was strong and he
had
unusual techniques i see
what exactly is the lightning of tamway
that is a technique belonging to
ghinichiro's
i'll wager it was quite the sight his
mentor dom away
there aren't many masters of the sword
like
these nuts
it's like she's dancing when you look
into her eyes
okay metal i'm sorry
that i didn't put two and two together
i was completely taken by her
and it almost killed me exactly
taranator great point great point
immortality
that will be quite the barrel and in
battle the plans and desires of those
involved churn endlessly if you hesitate
you'll be swept away and lose the battle
that's right
best you keep it in mind sakura i'm
happy you can make a stream
and you lose
don't ever hesitate chat
whoa
i'm scared i'm leaving
what the heck just happened bro
what the [ __ ]
anyway
[Music]
yeah if you have
if you guys have ideas on what games you
would like to see me play or make
content on
please let me know
so you've met with lord ishin yes
he thanked me for defeating kenichiro
i see to think that lord can eat you
apple tales should go as far as to drink
the rejuvenating that's a no for me
chief but okay
sediment that's what we call a
particularly concentrated part of the
rejuvenation bloodborne i can't actually
i might be able to on a playstation now
on pc
but my ps4 doesn't even work anymore
one becomes able to withstand the quarry
that would be fatal to anyone else
my mentor dogen devoted much what types
of games you play
i am all of his works man documents
medicines everything i'm like a mutt
when it comes to gaming
like i can be a [ __ ]
normie
and play
call of duty
or i'm playing sakura and that's a big
in between there you know what i'm
saying and i can play anything in
between too
i've been playing outer wilds on my xbox
and i [ __ ] love it
really cool game i thank you
for all of the help you've given me
almost sounds like you're bidding sake
is made from the blood of virgins
[Music]
yikes
so i will stay here in the castle come
and speak to me whenever you please i
will provide my assistance to you as a
doctor
barbie girl's dream house
god damn it
goodbye
fine
i forgot about this segment is all
talking
this dust is awful i have returned oh
wolf
you're back the heck is peggle
i did pokemon the mortal blade pokemon
key to sever anymore
it's a sword that has the power to kill
the undying
it can be found at sempo temple yeah i
tried downloading one of your barbie
games and you almost gave me
a virus
for my part i hunted for any books that
may contain clues about the aroma of the
fountainhead it seems lord takeru indeed
sought a way to reach the divine realm
so far i found one piece of relevant
information what is it a flower
oh yeah
a flower we get the flower from the from
the ape
what is
lore takeru left it behind i was looking
for information on the fountainhead
aroma and how it relates to the divine
realm one thousand percent gave me a
virus
and the book speaks of a white lotus
flower that grows where the water pools
deeply it appears to be one component of
the fountain react to barney a place you
know fountainhead you got your guys
ideas are perhaps in a deep valley
interesting indeed
the fountainhead water should flow into
there where is this sunken valley it's
beyond the woods to the rear of the
castle there's a shrine dedicated to the
white serpent deep in the woods as the
name implies
the sunken valley is just below that
place there's no proper path down there
but a man of your talent could navigate
it
worst nightmare oh that gave me idea to
play little nightmares
i miss little nightmares that could be
awesome
my lord
please
take a look at
it this me of hirata
and of that night
play with my heart
forgive me wolf you brought it all this
way to me
but i don't have need for it anymore
i've heard there's a rundown temple on
the outskirts of yeah before you guys
came uh to this stream and maybe you've
watched a couple of my videos
did you expect me to be more like vati
video
of it there yes i will make the offering
because i'm i i'm not
oh
i'm not that door marked with the
outline of a person lord eachine once
called it a shinobi shortcut i haven't a
clue how it works but seeing as he
mentioned shinobi
i thought you might know
well i bet you just put your body up
next to it
like this
wow that was so complicated
could never figure that one out
anyway let's keep
going what the french toast sticks
i didn't realize these are all out here
what are you talking to him for
what are you doing hmm
oh
i didn't realize you were here the
sculptor has been coughing blood i took
a sample of this blood for my dragon rot
research assembly you beat the barbie
games
blood that he's coughed up the color of
the blood itself appears to be i've
never played them
stagnant but
the sculptor's blood alone you know
because of the virus
is there anything i can do
yes
bring me samples of blood coughed up by
others that suffer from the dragon rock
that sounds like more coveted i'll be
able to learn more about the disease if
i come across anyone afflicted by the
dragon rot i'll ask them
oh little
nightmares you were disappointed in
little nightmares oh my god i can't
imagine i
love little nightmares
do we go fight lady butterfly
um
we could
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
i'll give you a virus for real okay i'm
sorry
hear the bear speak to you
hi alex
they caught the vid
one
will stir your thoughts
and awaken old memories from their
slumber
i will say the story here
of sakiro is
very very simple
and i guess after playing elden ring for
four months
i think anything is simple after that
you know what i mean
damn this looks real good on my 4k
monitor
okay i'm sorry i'm over it i'm done
i'm done with the 4k thing
hey it's the whoo
guy
you're
the son of
owl
what happened what happened
thieves
had heroic estate you must
hurry
the divine
what year is it what year is it
what here
an odd question tell me
what is this
the sculptor mentioned an old memory
i don't remember any of this yeah i
would say elden ring is mainly
i would say eldon ring is more
confusing with the lore
what do you guys think of eldon rings
lore
obviously i've made videos on it just
talking about what i've found
but
i still think it's a it's very confusing
like crazy
we got doggies
i don't like hurting the dogs
more fork
oh wait isn't there um someone on the
beach we can talk to you down here yeah
yeah
[Music]
come here
come here
okay that's fine
um
oh yeah i forget i can swim
there you are
this is odd
i think the lord is great but it's not
for the community but
if it's not for the community
i'd have no idea what was going on
right
like if it wasn't for people talking
about it you wouldn't know what was
happening yeah that makes sense
divine grass
withered red gourd
i'm good on this for now
very strange
but [ __ ] it
these guys are freaking fast man
what the heck
[Applause]
hey you there
[Applause]
very similar to morrowind
i've never played morrowind
i played skyrim
i didn't play oblivion or morrowind
i think i was only a call of duty gamer
at that time
when those came out
like the only games i played back in the
day
nice nice nice nice
did i not rest guys
again
i don't think i did i have no gourd
seeds
[Music]
the hammer or that axe music's very
heavy for you my guy
need to hit the gym whoops
are you hiding
okay
i mean so far as i'm playing this
i don't think
the uh experience of playing elden ring
and then this game
oh god he kicked some dirt in my face
i don't think
it's any different from when i first
played it
i want to talk to this guy okay the dog
[ __ ] off good
skyrim is a ubisoft game compared to
morrowind
oh god
sorry buddy
oh god dude i'm completely stuck awesome
you make it uh god's stopping celestial
hold on
[Music]
let me get out of this pickle
there we go
god stopping celestial events and means
of god's being locked away god is using
you for their own means
uh or to overthrow the current
established religion what the [ __ ] did i
just read what are you talking
about i'm distracted
you make it to the cloud district
often
[Music]
nope don't know what you're talking
about got home candy's in the laundry
room
tastes like tide pods what do i do that
sounds
like a problem
you should uh
maybe go to the hospital
but if there's any offerings we could
give them the lord
enough we don't take from buddha how
many times do i have to tell you before
it sinks into your thick skull yeah i
tried playing uh assassin's creed
uh
the new one the vikings one what is it
called
i did not like it
not a fan
ball hollow yeah
it just feels awful
i don't know
like the story
ooh acts of the monkey cool
um
that's a pretty good shinobi prosthetic
it just doesn't
feel good
valhalla
a roost oh a lot of roosters okay i'm
going to avoid them
anything over here for me to do hello
besides all these roosters
leave maybe please please
isn't there somebody back here if i
remember right
oh we're all the way back here sheesh
okay
it was better than odyssey i didn't play
odyssey i i haven't played uh assassin's
creed since
uh unity i think
which is quite a while
long time
i really liked the original ones
the original uh assassin's creeds
i mean i really if i jump down there i
really have to go all the way back like
this
dude
wait
okay i was holding left and it wasn't
going so i thought i couldn't go
yeah i thought unity was pretty cool
[Music]
okay we need to find a place to rest
because i got nothing going on right now
bruh
what's in here
who
who are you i'm not a thief
you're the young lords
oh thank goodness yeah black flag was
good that's true i did enjoy black flag
they've already climbed the hill and set
the estate on fire it looked as if the
young lord had no way to escape i beg of
you shinobi
please rescue the young lord i just
didn't have any interest after
i think it was unity
thank you
okay
neat
well we're really not gonna find like
anywhere
[Applause]
we're moving forward
keep it going people
oh [ __ ]
oh come on
i think i can just carry this guy over
and over again
[Music]
okay i didn't think you would do that
hard
i heard black flag
immediately thought henry rollins and
not assassin's creed
well you thought wrong
bruh
[Music]
okay
nice
over there people
all right
yeah
there we go
now let's actually rest
while this guy's attacking me sweet
i always forget to rest because i'm a
stupid
uh poopoo head sometimes
breath of light recovers posture upon
executing a successful death blow
we like that that's nice with it
still going
quite the tenacious fella
i would have wanted a long break by now
i mean we've only been streaming for
three hours
i did get posture back sweet
oh punk tangent
i'm pretty basic when it comes to music
i like foo fighters i like tool i like
nirvana
i like
i like like all kinds of stuff
i'm pretty much a basic [ __ ] i would
say
run boy run
yeah let's just go this way okay
what up big man
are you
okay
i forget you could swim
cool do the pieces fit
what does that mean i just like tool
good god damn band
oh also i should ask this
are there games coming out soon that you
guys are excited about
okay let's get rid of all these guys
i liked assassin's creed was it was
syndicate after unity because i don't
i don't think i tried syndicate but i
did hear about it
and i watched some of it and i was like
not super interested
why was i oh he broke my posture
he's arrows dude
yoda
there's no way you're over the age of
12. like there's just no [ __ ] way
dude
like holy crap
you just say the dumbest [ __ ] in chat
sometimes
okay that didn't work
like just the dumbest [ __ ]
why didn't you rick roll because i was
scared it was uh copyrighted
the heck do you meet these guys
that seems overpowered
that's overpowered
i'm kind of excited for modern warfare
2. it looks pretty good
axe prosthetic oh yeah
i remember that now
can i equip that now
oh
oh no i gotta go back okay i will
i don't think i have to deal with many
shields
damn this looks good in 4k okay i'm
sorry i just had to say it this looks
sick this looks so good
god damn
oh yeah it's my dad
father
uh
it's you
i'm afraid i
made a bit of a blunder
perhaps the years have finally caught up
with me ah
don't bother tending to my wounds no
point
[Music]
it's too late
you must what screen tearing
what are you talking about
the key to the secret temple i didn't
see none of that
mansion
you'll find him
many hours would otherwise be chad like
life no doubt nowadays i only play some
from software games
what did i used to play so many games in
years of yore
wasting many hours of what would been
otherwise otherwise be a chad like
the iron life
yes the master is absolute war
protect your master
with
your life
okay then
winky face
father i'm dead
might as well just go up i died
i know i know
oh there is screen tearing
oh i see that okay not on my screen
i see it though i see it
seemed to be only with the fire though
i thought it was 8k
shut the [ __ ] up
if you're not streaming in 24k then what
are you even doing
where's the 4d smell effects
oh i see
so if you guys are watching in 1080p
does it stream fair
[Music]
probably not
okay what's in here hello
let me just hug your wall really quick
hello
okay
only 4k imagine
what's in here
okay those guys can just swing through
whatever the [ __ ] they want
like they do not care
yeah why can't i smell the fire in the
game
[Music]
yeah 512k
that's the only possible way to make it
to a hundred thousand subs
imagine being able to do that in real
life like that would be so freaking
badass
oh i found some old
cool
why does al look like harambe
i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know
okay
and this place is not doing so hot
well it's definitely hot
i could just reach to the top right
right right my bad i forgot
[Music]
bum bum
yeah we don't like talking about that
kind of stuff we don't talk about view
count we don't talk about
sub count
we'll talk about that [ __ ]
we are here to enjoy
the stream
and have a good time
i don't care how many people are here i
care about the people that are here not
the people that are not here
which is why what yoda said earlier was
[ __ ] stupid
would never forgive me should i fail
let us fight together yeah let's go
[Applause]
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] we got shield boys
subs deleted
okay i thought never mind
that was my bad
and he annihilates posture holy [ __ ]
oh i didn't have he broke my posture
dude
it works both ways
if i got him i might as well use them
right
oh we're all out okay
i don't like that he's right next to the
shield guy did our boy die no
[Music]
oh we're just gonna double that up huh
okay
what the holy [ __ ]
i forgot about that attack that's sick
i'm near a rock
[Music]
[Music]
i would like to not be where i'm
currently at right now there we go
that's bad
oh my god that just could not have gone
worse
could not have gone worse
the rick video felt like a treat for us
who liked to tune into the streams it
kind of was
it was it was more for you guys
the people who were there because i said
i'd do it i said 69 000 subs
and i'd make a rick video and we got
there and i did it
and it was fun
it's a good video
i died in
4k yep when i die it's
everybody can see it in super high
quality 4k
now we're at like 71 000 right
let us fight together
awesome i didn't even know you were
attacking okay
okay
get some iframes i like it oh
not good
not even attacking me that's kind of
cringe not going to cap on a stack
skilly squilly with y'all
wow
i mean i didn't kill this guy oh you
mean my buddy i guess he does respond
it's trees
not doing
not doing me any favors
yeah he responds he comes back
because technically we're in a dream
this ain't even real
or a dream
memory
something like that i don't know
it's fine
yeet
yeah i'll use bloodhound step next time
yup yup
what the [ __ ] i just got sniped from
across the map that's great that's
excellent
kill the other guy mate kill the other
guy
get rid of shield boys
getting rid of shield boys
bruh
keep distracting him my friend
don't die
don't die
all right
i failed
if i got those i'm gonna use them
i'm in a tree
love it love it love it love that for me
excellent
[Music]
damn
i will go [ __ ] myself
absolutely
uh
the grabs
back it up
get some posture back
gotta focus
good
nice
nice
[Music]
oh that was just a weird attack i did
not like that attack at all i didn't
like that
okay
good [ __ ]
good [ __ ]
[Music]
good
get maybe one in there nice
play it safe get that posture back
let them spray
gonna be a little gross fatty
excellent
nope play it safe play safe get some
stuff back
up buddy drink up
[Music]
oh very good
nice
[Music]
no i we triggered the other dudes
oh this is pain
you're not involved stay away
you did the opposite of what i told you
to do
it was all going so well
okay very tense moment
i actually buried that as i hit this guy
close one
nice
all right that got a lot harder than it
needed to be at the end but we did it
excellent excellent
good stuff good stuff
dowsing powder excellent
how many times can i say excellent
oh [ __ ]
not like this just just
just know
right next to a
buddha statue
excellent
who the [ __ ] are you
hello
it wouldn't stop
wouldn't stop what up jose
the young master
the young master is deep in the mansion
my son inosuke went to rescue him
so he's probably fine but
am i considered a rogue shinobi already
like i just went to go
i don't know where i was
let's see
oh i got four prayer beats
nice
nice
it's attack power don't need to
all good
uh i have three skills that's great
blowing water reduces the amount of
damage to posture when attacked by an
enemy with a sword
we will take that we like that as well
my information
hello
hey there's your guy
you
the young masters
read the prayer be description i
wouldn't go in there if i were you
dreadful illusion techniques oh god
without us look at how that guy died
right next cannot be overcome take this
it's not much
but it's what i have
nap seed oh we like this listen
without a snapseed you cannot overcome
that illusion technique
i tried my best to be his guardian but
look at me now the harada line is
finished
i must save my mother at the very least
yep you do that buddy
i did not want to talk to you again
sorry sorry sorry sorry
okay
we want to equip
oh only one snapseed
use some ninjutsu if our heart desires
yeah
yeah okay
for every necklace descriptions are all
different
i did not know that that's pretty cool
though
can i read them now though
father gold mass golden jock strap true
the butterflies
everyone is gone
the butterflies my lord
illusion technique
it's been a long time
do what must be done
yes
or japanese voices creepy
i've only played this game in english so
i have no idea
she's pretty [ __ ] cool no cap
yeah we know all about vitality and
posture at this point
[Music]
yep she always follows up with that
right there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
okay
decent start
whoa
how am i alive what
[Music]
[Music]
how you got so many knives girl
there's so many what are they called
kunai
i think
[Music]
ow
i think that's a sweep i can't tell if
that's a sweep
it's kind of an odd one
like it's hard to visually see
even in 4k
[Music]
that's definitely a sweep because she's
yeah she's pretty low when she does it
hmm
nice
a little ichi honor
[Music]
there we go okay stage one i mean not
bad
okay i have no more
thingies though
no more gourds
doesn't she go up there yeah she's right
there
it's all an illusion
what the [ __ ]
stop it
ah
okay so
wait
no
not what i wanted
i probably shouldn't have used it
oh my god that doesn't even get rid of
all of them
oh no
i could just wait it out as well
because she did that
oh
you're still just a puppy
okay lady that was not bad for a first
attempt because this is really [ __ ]
hard
this this [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] guy
i think i always just waited it out
pretty sure
oh
hey let's
let's do that one again huh
dances with wolves sand and shoe
yeah let's try that one again that was
uh
damn
your openings are quite strange
[Music]
nice
dude
[Music]
yeah let me just pull out that like like
out of [ __ ] nowhere
[Music]
whew
nice
okay
yeah yeah you now see why uh melania
would get absolutely annihilated
yeah
with this combat absolutely
what the heck is that
oh
cute
get a little hit in every now and then
she's already over it
i forgot no i
forgot again no
no i thought
all right all right if that's the only
way i'm dying that's
that's a good sign
it's not but
i'm feeding myself positivity right now
definite positivity
hesitation means defeat
i was told that
god damn it
[Music]
[Music]
it goes so well
until it
goes not well
did that make any sense
is she just letting me
do this
[Music]
[Music]
where'd you go
cool the camera [ __ ] me
you've been manscaped
it's good it's good i like that
impressive boy
my non 4k monitor would survive
i booted how are you
oh just an immediate
illusion
get rid of him lady
[Music]
no
no no
okay
excellent
excellent
wow
[Music]
yep saw that coming saw that coming mile
away
not even close
i thought maybe it's a mercury counter
real balloon it's not
it's not
[Music]
dude
[ __ ] god
no i i thought i had a thing
dang it
reading philosophy or if you like to
read it
uh no
no i don't
no
sorry
all right
hey you gonna start all right hey you
know
that's a strong start
that's a strong start sometimes
that i just have no uh chance of uh
of killing
or apparently
avoiding
okay do it do it again
i did it
wow
okay
[Music]
nice throw idiot
[Music]
[Music]
no the camera
i really gotta be careful there man
i just have to be so careful or it's
over
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
as i say to be careful
and then i just do the exact same thing
to get hit
i'm just getting that flow
[Music]
okay
okay
excellent
okay
okay okay
lady butterfly gonna tone your balls
excellent excellent progressive boy brew
this is one of the e games easiest
bosses i completely disagree with that
what
no shot
ah
so
[Music]
ah those little [ __ ]
[Applause]
i one shot at gennichiro
man
first try again each hero
i mean she pretty much just insta kills
me if she gets off one of those
unblockables that i don't dodge
[Music]
[Music]
i also have to be so
focused
this game's hard to stream
what
okay
i've dodged that every time
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
really good start nice
impressive
[Applause]
oh god
oh god
[Music]
she's just talking out here
okay
oh [ __ ]
cool
yeah that was close
[Music]
[Music]
nice
okay there we go
yeah i don't know where people say that
she's easy she's not easy at all
if you're not perfect she
she kills you pretty quick
forget what happens here
that's right i remember
[ __ ]
i was thinking my head like how do we
get out of here
didn't deflect that one
that was that that was owl's [ __ ]
sword yeah
looked like it
oh you can hear that burning his hand
you [ __ ] bravely
on my back
i cannot throw away such loyalty
no
[Music]
loyal wolf take my blood and live again
take my blood
nice
all right guys
i think that's a good place to stop for
today
i am getting tired this game requires a
lot of focus dude it really does elden
ring i feel like i don't really even
have to focus that much like you just
[ __ ] roll bro
depending on the boss
i don't know if anyone else has asked if
they didn't catch it but what headset to
use this is a audio technica i forget
which one
audio technica though i really like
um
a
a50s
something like that
who the [ __ ] are you
so friend he was shinobi or what hmm
yes know what always say nothing
i see
fair enough anyways you came at a good
time wanna buy some information friend
i'm late because of work
you get from this guy okay just he's
just another merchant till next time
friend
all right interesting
anyway i think i'm going to call it
there for today this game requires a lot
of focus
elton ring i don't really feel like i
have to focus all that much
because elden ring is kind of i would
say elden ring is one of the easier
from software games whereas sakiro is
definitely one of the harder ones for
sure uh i'd say on the level of
difficulty like bloodborne
um because bloodborne is pretty [ __ ]
hard too you guys haven't played that
um yeah it makes me tired to focus this
hard it really does
and streaming at the same time
it's pretty difficult but anyway
infinite confetti that's actually sick i
want to buy that
um
we'll pick this up either tomorrow or
sometime
we'll you know
we'll figure it out we'll see if we want
to continue on or not i like it but
we'll see we'll see
um
i really want to play the quarry i
wonder how that would do either doing a
video series or on the stream i have no
idea but we're gonna find out
we're gonna figure it out
but i'm gonna call it there for today
appreciate you guys being here really do
um
check out manscaped in the description
man i'd really appreciate it or go watch
the newest video the rick video that
would help me out a lot
um just to get that video trending a bit
more i would really like um
yeah follow me on twitter everything's
linked in the description so go check
that out if you want
um
we are on the road to 100k subs dude
we're at like 71
over 70 000 so that's already freaking
nuts
absolutely incredible
so yeah we're almost at 71 500 so next
stream i not sure when i just kind of
stream when i want to and today i wanted
to so we'll see
it's also really [ __ ] hot in this
room as well everything is making me
tired
in here so
hey
love you guys thank you very much for
being here check out everything in the
description if you want
uh i'll be back soon
um i want to make another uh uh elden
ring video on why i think the game is
like
quote unquote dying
i don't really think it's dying but you
guys will see in the video that's that's
my next video idea that i want to make
in the next day or two so
other than that you all have a great
rest of your day and i will see you guys
again soon